in china they're waging war on the
weather a drought so severe they're
firing rockets into the sky to make it
rain
the practice is known as cloud seeding
drones and rockets are used to sow
silver iodide into the clouds the
substance has a similar structure to ice
and changes the cloud's structure to
increase the chance of rain
after more than two months of extreme
heat it is desperately needed
right now we are rather sufficient in
our artificial influence rocket supply
we have strengthened monitoring of the
weapon and carried out artificial
precipitation operations accordingly to
further relieve the drought and high
temperature in the area the drought is
the worst china's seen since records
began 60 years ago decimating farmland
along the basin of the yangtze
normally one of china's main arteries it
supports nearly half a billion people
and a third of the country's crops
this was poyang lake in the central
jiangxi province 12 months ago high
water and lush vegetation throughout but
what a difference a year makes a flood
outlet reduced to a trickle and what was
green turned to brown
teams of officials have been dispatched
to the stricken areas diverting rivers
for irrigation and scouring the
mountains for whatever sources remain to
pump water to the villages where
supplies are drying up many tenths every
day we trek for some 12 kilometers to
inspect at least four villages where we
check for possible blockage in water
channels or leaks throughout the water
pipes
in some provinces factories have shut
down and cities have imposed blackouts
after reservoirs used to run
hydroelectric power stations ran low
and as the heat wave begins to subside
attentions now turn to assessing the
damage
iva bennett sky news